a woman accusing president Trump of  sexual assault wants Congress to  investigate the 19 claims of sexual  misconduct against him  Rachel crooks told The Washington Post  mr. Trump kissed her without her consent  in a trump tower office lobby in 2006  the president responded yesterday on  Twitter saying he never met her and that  the encounter never happened  Brooks fired back in an interview with  CBS this morning I'm not surprised you  know that he would deny the allegations  because that seems to be his common  response but my my response is it  absolutely happened President Trump is  the one that seems to be immune to all  of this for for whatever reason  apparently we don't want to hold the  president accountable but I think if  anyone should be held accountable it  should be him crooks is running for a  seat in Ohio State Legislature we asked  the White House for a comment but have  not yet received a response